going to begin though with a growing
International concern big concern over
the fate of an Iranian athlete who is
missing after defying her government
she's a rock climber her name is El Nas
reckaby she has not been heard from
since competing without a hijab at a
competition in Seoul South Korea now
this comes at a time of historic unrest
in Iran after the death of a woman in
the custody of the so-called morality
police Elizabeth Palmer has more on this
story
all eyes were on El Nazareth ABI earlier
this week as she scaled a climbing wall
in Seoul South Korea without her
headscarf but once the Asian climbing
championships ended friends say she
vanished her decision to climb without
her scarf broke the Islamic Republic's
rules for women in sport but colleagues
say it was deliberate
and especially pointed in the context of
thousands of Iranian women who've been
protesting for the past month against
compulsory hijab
the protests follow the death and police
custody of 24-year-old masa amini for
her allegedly unislamic dress human
rights groups say run-ins with the
security forces have left more than 200
protesters dead one's video of Rick
Habib bear-headed went viral CBS sources
say she was invited to the Iranian
Embassy in Seoul on a roof and once
there stripped of her passport and phone
and put on a plane for Tehran the
Iranian Embassy in Seoul tweeted a
picture of her today head covered and
said she had left Korea this morning but
reports that she'd gone missing were
false news friends and contacts say she
hasn't been seen in Iran yet though and
they fear she may have been taken
directly from the airport to prison
the international Iranian opposition has
been working hard to publicize Rick
Abby's apparent disappearance hoping
that the Uproar will keep her out of
jail and that she may instead be forced
to for example record a TV confession
saying that she'd forgotten her hijab
but at the moment there is no solid news
on her whereabouts Tony
we'll keep waiting and hoping for the
best Liz thank you very much